Have you noticed your favorite celebs choosing high-tops over high heels lately?
I'm Victoria Keelan with Buzz 60.
A-list celebs like Jennifer Lopez are rocking a much more casual look these days...
...when they hit the streets.
It may be surprising to see supermodels like Gisele and Miranda Kerr...
...ditching their stilettos in favor of sneakers, but these aren't just any sneakers.
These high-tops have a built-in wedge heel...
...that gives the height of a stiletto, but with total comfort.
Some daring fashionistas like Kate Bosworth even pair them with skirts and dresses.
Alicia Keys is such a fan of the trend, she launched her own pair with Reebok,...
...and unlike some of the pricier versions, hers are less than a hundred bucks.
Sporty brands like Lacoste and Puma have even gotten in on the wedge sneaker trend as well.
Now, if you've got big bucks to spend,...
...the Isabel Marant wedge sneakers are a celeb favorite but they run over $500.
If you want to try the trend on the cheap, check out these styles from Steve Madden.
The wedge sneaker trend definitely gives a whole new meaning to pumped up kicks.
Buzz 60.
Now you know, pass it on.